In 1950, Dr. Abraham Jacob Winetram left France for Sri Lanka and India, with the intention
of staying only two months, to meet with spiritual masters, in particular with Ramana Maharishi
and Sri Aurobindo. As fate would have it, he met Ma Anandami soon after his arrival.
Following this meeting, he decided to follow the holy woman and later became a monk or Swami
in Ma's organization, taking the name of Swami Vijayananda, the victory of bliss. Swami
Vijayananda never returned to France and spent nearly 60 years in India, including 17 years as
a hermit in the mountains of the Himalayas. This Jyoti grandpa, or sweet grandfather, as some
French followers like to call him, welcomed Westerners to Ma's Ashram in Kankal, where the
tom of Anandami Ma is located, until his death on April 5, 2010 at the age of 95. Today Swami Vijayananda
is an object of veneration for Christians, Jews, Buddhists, Hindus and others at his grave in
peer lasheirs, serving as a bridge between East and West as well as a central element to the
worship of Anandami Ma. Just imagine that a tree, a beautiful strong old beach, for instance,
approaches you with calm steps. What would you feel? Oh, I have gone crazy, you would think,
or perhaps I am dreaming, you would wonder, finally when you realize that you are neither dreaming,
nor are you seeing an illusion, you will understand you have entered a new dimension of reality.
This is how the German novelist, Malita Marshmart, described her first encounter with Anandami Ma,
in her book, in Countering Bliss, my journey through India, with Anandami Ma.
Mah Anandami is considered a true giant in Indian spirituality, who is revered by people in the
East and the West alike as one among the great saints of modern India, along with saints like Ramakrishna,
Vivekananda, Orobin Noghosh, Ramana Maharishi and Paramahansa Yogananda.
Anandami Ma literally means Blisspermated Mother. It was as early as 1920s that people
close to her began to realize the essence of mother divine in her and started calling her
Mataji, or often just Ma. It was one of her early disciples called Bayaji, who gave her
the title of Ma Anandami, meaning mother full of Bliss, soon people all over the country
and from different quarters of the world who flocked to her for spiritual elimination,
started calling her Anandami Ma, or Blisspermated Mother.
On April 30, 1896, in a remote rural village of Kura in East Bengal, a girl child was born to
a poor, but devout Vaishnava Brahmin couple. They named her Nirmala Sundari, meaning
Immaculate Beauty, or Tentless Beauty. According to Professor Bithika Mukaji, the principal
biographer of Anandami Ma, she was a very detached child right from her early years, showing
little interest in her surrounding environment. People often thought she was intellectually challenged,
but this detachment did not mean any withdrawal from life. Nirmala Sundari was indeed a very
happy child. She communed with animals and trees, like Saint Francis of Assisi, an often fell into
spiritual chances. At the age of 13, Nirmala Sundari was married to a much older person, Ramani Mohan
Chakravarti. He later became her disciple and she called him Bholena, one of the names of Lord Shiva.
Ma went through her marriage life with complete commitment, treating her husband like a devoted wife,
but she never consummated her marriage with sexual union or procreation. It is said that whenever
the thoughts of physical attraction and lust occurred to her husband, Ma's body would assume the
terrible and awe-inspiring form of the goddess Kali and the poor husband would retreat in submission
and guilt. Bholena was troubled and frustrated at first, but was gradually convinced that his wife
was in fact a manifestation of the divine mother. He later took spiritual initiation from his wife
and began to relate to her as his guru. In a remarkable reversal from the perspective of Darma Shastra
or the Hindu code, he spent the rest of his life as his wife disciple, caring for her physical
well-being as she seemed completely uninterested in her body and mediating between her and her growing
number of devotees. Ma in fact distanced herself from the traditional role of a Hindu married woman
and broke the ideal of the perfect Hindu woman or Pativrata by her refusal to toe the line.
Karen Pechalis, who undertook an interesting study on the female gurus in Asia,
considers this refusal of the socially defined role of a woman as a key instrumental element
in conferring the charismatic status Ma on and the my head among other female saints and gurus.
In 1918, at the age of 22, Ma moved with her husband to Bajitpur in eastern Bengal,
there she initiated an intense and prolonged phase of spiritual self-discipline or sadhana. Unlike
other sages and yogic masters, she never received any direction or lessons from a guru. She taught
herself and was able to perform the very yogic postures, asanas and symbolic and ritualistic gestures,
Madras, all by herself spontaneously. Ma called this phase sadhana Lila,
Lila means play or game. For Ma there was nothing to be attained spiritually through sadhana,
although she learned, practiced and perfected it without any masters. Her state had always been
one of spiritual realization according to Ma. Like the famous Sanskrit scholar and theologian
Professor Gopinat Kaviraj, whose writings were instrumental in exposing the spiritual power
of this illiterate woman to the academic world observed samadhi or no samadhi. She is where she
always has been. She knows no change, no modification, no alteration. She is always poised in the
self-same awareness as a supreme and integral universality. Anandami Ma continued her sadhana
or self-disciplining and that eventually led into her initiation. On August 3, 1922, Ma conducted her own
initiation simultaneously becoming the disciple Shishya, the master Guru and the divinity,
Ishta, all the integral rituals as laid down in the scriptures were spontaneously performed by her
to detail. Later Ma said on her initiation, as the master Guru, I revealed the mantra as a disciple
Shishya, I accepted it and started to recite it. The mantra now replaced the names of God,
which I had been repeating earlier. As the realization dawned within me, that the master,
the mantra, the Lord, Ishta and the disciple are one. By this unconventional act of self-initiation,
Anandami Ma distinguished herself from most of the Guru's insages and became an exceptional saint.
In 1924, Anandami Ma moved to Dhaka, the capital city of Bangladesh with her husband. It is
during the period that people started recognizing her spiritual mastery and the first disciples flock
to her, including Bhayaji, who first called her, Ma Anandami, describing her as the mother saturated
with joy. Slowly but steadily, the number of people who recognize her spiritual
prowess increased and people far and wide began to hear about her spiritual ecstases and
started coming to meet her and seek spiritual counsel. Many saw her as an incarnation of the divine
mother, others saw her as a being that had attained the perfect realization, Jeevan Mukta, a good
number of people flock to her, hearing of her reputation and wanted to see her perform miracles,
clairvoyance and healing. From the early 1930 onwards, Ma started traveling throughout the
country, visiting temples and holy sites and meeting with her devotees, her life became an
unending procession of religious gatherings, such sons, for the rest of her mundane life,
Ma followed this pattern of travelling and meeting, leading the life of a renauncient
and a spiritual guru to her followers. She interacted with strange crowds as a spiritual guide
and spoke about spiritual matters with authority, all the while referring to herself at a little girl.
Her fame spread slowly but steadily and many scholars and sages wanted to know about her
and came to meet her. To their surprise, she spoke to them with ease and authority about
even the most complex philosophical concepts. They could instantly recognize the higher state of
spiritual elevation, this illiterate girl had attained. During the next few years, many prominent
people, being gollies and non-bingolies alike, had the opportunity to meet Ma and become her devotees.
In 1933, Kamla Nehru, wife of Pandit Jewahar Lal Nehru, met Ma and became her devotee,
Kamla's daughter, Indira Gandhi. Future Prime Minister of India would come to seek Ma's
spiritual guidance throughout her life. Other well-known Indian devotees who met Ma during the
period included the saint Shiva Nanda, the yogi Yogananda and Mahatma Gandhi, as well as numerous
politicians, including the President of the Republic, Dr. Rajendra Prasad and the Vice President
and Philosopher, Servapali Rada Krishna and Pandit Nehru. Within the ensuing decades, many European
visitors to India had Ma's darshan and became her devotees. Ma's foremost foreign devotees
include Abraham Jacob Vintrope of French Physician, now Swami Vijayananda, British photographer,
Richard Lanay, and the French film producer, Ahno Dijande, in her pilgrimages throughout India,
Ma attracted a vast number of followers and although she never encouraged it,
Ashrams were constructed to welcome her, an organisation was created in 1952,
the Sri Sri Anandami Sangha, making Ma the first woman in the history of India to be represented
by a movement of such size. While on a visit to India in 1936, Guru Paramahansa Yogananda,
the founder of Self-realization Fellowship in America and the world renowned teacher of Kriya Yogan,
went to meet Anandami Ma, as suggested by his niece. The moment Ma saw him, she got down from
the car, she had got in, as she was about to go on a journey and walked up to him, saying aloud,
in childlike joy. Father, finally you have come. Guru Yogananda was surprised by this,
as he was meeting her for the first time. Sometime later, at his request, Ma visited him
in his school in Ranjee, in his book autobiography of a yogi, Yogananda describes how Ma responded
when asked to tell something about herself. There is so little to tell father, before I came on
this earth father, I was the same, as the little girl, I was the same. I grew into womanhood,
but still I was the same. Even afterwards, through the dance of creation, changes around me
in the hall of eternity, I shall be the same, fully convinced of Ma's divinity, Yogananda remark
that Anandami Ma was always one with the eternal.
In the last decade of her life, Anandami Ma's devotees numbered in the hundreds of thousands,
and Ashrams, hospitals, and schools had been established in her name all over India.
At the age of 86 on August 28, 1982, Ma took Mahasamadhi, or passed from the physical world
in her ashram and dehradhu. Next day, in accordance with Ma's wishes, her body was taken in a
procession, tended by thousands in morning to conquer ashram and haridvar. On Sunday, August 29,
Ma Anandami was buried as the realized being, and ever since her shrine has become a place of
worship and pilgrimage, renowned for its spiritual power, her ashrams continued to function in
honour of her, hered by various male renouncers, or senyasans, and run lightly by celibate women,
or brahmacharans. Her thousands of household devotees worship her daily in their homes,
and gather each week to participate in spiritual practices in her name.
Ma Anandami's life and teachings do not yield to easy categorization and labels, various
disciples, scholars and observers of her life, and work have wondered if Ma was just an extraordinary
mystic, or an avatar, or is she in fact the absolute self in bodily manifestation. In the words of
her Italian devotee, medium or mother is not a human being, like all the others, she is divine
light, clad in a human form. Alexander Lipsky, in his book on Ma, makes a curious observation
that though many a skill photographer has tried to capture Anandami Ma, most of the pictures had
turned out to be very distinctly different. Lipsky likes to conclude that we are witnessing in her
person, the infinitely varying aspects of the cosmos. The spiritual teachings of Anandami Ma,
likewise defy labels, and cannot be said to belong to any particular school of Indian philosophy.
Anandami Ma never thought of herself as a guru, and constantly called herself this little girl.
But at the same time she gave spiritual counseling and instructions. Her method of teaching was simple,
she chose a simple language and spoke often through parables, like Sri Ramakrishna did,
or like Jesus Christ. According to Ma, irrespective of which religious path one embraces,
the aim of religion must be to pierce through the veil of delusion to discover the underlying
oneness, and ultimately to merge with the one. This is the foremost, made the only duty of man.
We may try to summarize the teachings of Anandami Ma as focusing on two central themes
on self-realization and on action. She often reiterated that the supreme calling of every person
is to try and achieve self-realization and that all other obligations in life are secondary.
The true goal of our life on this earth is to realize God by knowing oneself. Hence the actions
that we do in our daily lives should be those which help us realize our divine nature.
Ma constantly spoke of the quest of finding our true self as our only possible way to escape from
Sansara and Karma. The endless cycles of rebirth in this world of alusary reality. It is clear
that even as she did not subscribe to any particular school, a teachings corresponded to the
philosophy of non-duality, her teachings essentially followed the path of Shankara's monest tradition
of Advethya. Ma always spoke of herself in the third person, calling herself as this body
or this little girl, an indication of the non-dual thought she practiced.
Anandami Oblis is a highly philosophical idea in Indian tradition. God or the absolute is described as
Satchitanan, a fusion of existence, consciousness and bliss. Thus, in Indian philosophical
tradition, bliss is not just joy or happiness. It is the ultimate manifestation of God himself.
This is the reason why Anandami Ma, the bliss permeated mother, was considered to be the
manifestation of the divine mother by her disciples. The bliss, Ma propagated and emanated
was the higher state of self-realization, attainable by everyone through proper Sathana and proper living.
The life of the blissful mother is an eloquent testimony to the abiding strength of Indian
spirituality. Ma Anandami's message is particularly appropriate, in a world where the notion of
progress is no longer taken from gospel truth and the whole array of our mortal values is
undergoing an agonizing reappraisal. Anandami Ma's diagnosis, the present disease of civilization
has over-secularization. She suggests that the cure from our severe illness cannot be bought
about by engineers, sociologists and psychologists, but by doctors of the soul. She prescribes
drastic revolution in our views and attitudes from outwardness to inwardness, from materialism,
to spirituality and from man's centredness to God's centredness, observes Alexander Lipsky.
Anandami Ma is now generally regarded as the very incarnation of bliss, a supreme manifestation
of the divine mother. She continues to teach and guide thousands of her followers even today.
The supreme lesson of bliss she taught by example lives on, where bliss reigns, fear must vanish,
says Alexander Lipsky of Ma's legacy. Ma Anandami was the embodiment of the truth proclaimed by
Tatrio Openishal, from joy springs the universe. Ma's presence is external in this world,
in her own words, one who passes away. In fact, merges into the one who is ever-existent.
Anandami Ma, the mother of bliss, is indeed ever-existent.
Ma Anandami Ma, the mother of bliss, is indeed ever-existent.